let's talk tv now because bachelor
nation just got off an emotional roller
coaster with clayton eckerd's season
some calling him the most hated bachelor
ever
et online's denny director caught up
with clayton and the one that got away
who came back susie
how long after iceland did you reach out
to clayton
so i pretty much reached out to clayton
immediately i slid into clayton's dms we
talked immediately that night for about
five hours and then we talked every
night after that for several weeks
before deciding to meet back up
i know clayton has had the biggest heart
and he genuinely has
not only cared for me but he has cared
about the other moments and and the
repercussions of his actions i created a
world of pain i caused a lot
of problems
clayton had his happy ending in last
night's season finale but not before
facing rachel and gabby they're the two
women he begged to stay only to change
his mind sending them both home from
iceland
am i able to walk you out
no
i owed it to those women to give them as
much closure as i could did you tell me
that you were in love with me because
you wanted to sleep with me
no no
no
when you say you love someone you're
assuming responsibility to protect them
i don't know if i was equipped to handle
dating multiple women i just feel
terrible that i hurt as many people as i
did
we have a feeling the pair will rebound
pretty quickly they will be
co-bachelorettes next season it's gabby
and rachel when they announced that they
were dual batch tourettes i
uh you know i had a big smile on my face
because
they're gonna both get their happy
ending as well and they deserve it
[Music]
you